you had a megaan slash I don't know if
I'd call her a stalker not a stalker no
she's in love with you just big fans
they both are I was like are you a fan
of my boyfriend he
is I think he's so funny I said in the
microphone I think this is the first
time I've had somebody at my show who
has made it abundantly clear they want
to F my boyfriend and all of this was
happening with her husband sitting right
next to her and so said at one point to
him like how do you feel about this he
goes I think uh he has a restraining
order against her and then I said oh
yeah are you blocked and she goes he
respond he
like I took my hoop earrings out people
went crazy what's going on there just
I've met her and her husband I don't
think we've messaged I think that I
respond to her comments after she's seen
a show MH she'll she'll put a comment
there and I responded